[Music]
here are a bunch of different kinds of
roller coasters this one is metal
this one is wood here's a wild mouse a
launched coaster
there are a lot of different kinds of
roller coasters but they all have a few
things in the comments
when you're designing a ride you have to
draw people
into the ride you want people to look at
that ride and say i got to give that a
try
this is one of the engineers who make
these roller coasters
i'm corey keeper and i'm an engineer and
partner at the gravity group
and these amusement rides like the ones
behind me that's my specialty
can you explain what a roller coaster
engineer does i will do
some of the structural engineering and
the mechanical engineering for the ride
so there might be an amusement park that
comes and they say
this is the plot of land that we have
this is the budget that we're thinking
what kind of ride can you give us
my job would be to say yeah i can fit
something in that spot
and it would be really cool if i could
use this hill over here
to add a terrain aspect to the ride
where i actually use some of the ground
features or if there are buildings or
other rides that i could interact with i
try to take all of that into
consideration
when we're designing a ride so why is it
that there are so many different types
of roller coasters
so when we design a roller coaster we're
trying to
to take something that's very much
driven by the same codes that would be
used to design a building
and we're working with those to create
something that gives you the illusion
that it's daring and adventurous
but at the same time it's all very
controlled that's the heart of what we
do
okay what are all the factors you have
to consider when building a roller
coaster
when we design a roller coaster for a
park the backbone of everything we do
follows safety standards that can vary
depending on the country
here in america we might have the astm
standards that we follow
europe has their own standards china has
their own standards so
we have to balance what is best for
the rider in terms of what are the safe
limits
but at the same time we're also making
it exciting we're making it
fun okay so what do all these roller
coasters have in common
the first thing is they all have a car
and on these cars
you have a set of different wheels you
have a
top wheel or a road wheel the second
wheel
would be called a side wheel sometimes
they're on the outside of the tracks
other times they're on the inside of the
tracks and that wheel
is used as you're going around a turn
when you're going over
a hill if you just had those two wheels
your
roller coaster would fly off the track
so there's a wheel
on the underside of the track called an
up stop or an
uplift wheel the track can be made of
wood or it can be made of steel
in between the rails there's something
called a cross tie
and that's something that is holding the
distance
between these rails constant then we
have supports
if you have a steel roller coaster you
have relatively few supports and large
spans
if you have a wooden roller coaster the
spans are tighter
and you have more of a traditional
lattice or trust structure
other similarities they all have a
breaking system which consists of a long
fin that runs through a pinch break
where you might have some differing
metal that would run through
a magnet and actually slow the train
using a magnetic force that's a more
comfortable more gradual way to bring
your ride
to a stop what forces do you have to
take into account when designing a
roller coaster
primarily a roller coaster is made up of
vertical g-forces
horizontal g-forces that's the side to
side and the longitudinal or a front to
back
g-forces so one g that's just me right
now i'm sitting here
i'm one g however as i'm going over
the hill that crest you might feel uh
what's called the air time and air time
those are the negative g-forces that's
where i feel like i could be launched
out of my seat
and then when you hit the valley you're
pushed into your seat
and that's a positive vertical g-force
we're putting a lot of twists and turns
into our rides as well
we call that banking we're controlling
the
horizontal g-forces or the side-to-side
forces
and so sometimes you might just bank at
45 degrees
you know and there might be other times
where we try to be
extreme and you you have what are called
over banked turns and that's something
where we go beyond 90 degrees
that's another tool and so now you can
start combining some elements a little
bit and so
you might have a certain vertical
g-force and horizontal g-force
and you can arrange them in such a way
that eventually you can do an inversion
and depending on the g-forces that you
have as you're going through this
inversion
you can have something where you feel
like you're floating and we would call
that like a zero g
roll so what are all the different types
of roller coasters out there
so when we're talking about a ride and
we're calling it a wooden roller coaster
or a steel roller coaster in general
what we're talking about is
what is the primary track material and a
wooden roller coaster
it's all about the stack we have these
plies of wood stacked on top of each
other
that we then put steel rails on with
wooden roller coasters
there were certain layouts like there'd
be out and back
roller coasters where you went out and
came back or there'd be twisters
or a cyclone style roller coaster like
in coney island
the cyclone is a wooden roller coaster
it's one of the oldest rides
still operating in the united states it
was built in 1927 i believe
and that's a compact ride it has a very
tight footprint
just kind of goes back and around on
itself
multiple times you know it has the drops
it has some of the turns
and it's just a rollicking fun ride to
many people
it just represents what a nostalgic
wooden roller coaster is
and is meant to be
you mentioned an out and back coaster
what is that an out and back roller
coaster
is all about air time and one of the
best out and back roller coasters
that i can think of is one called the
voyage and it's at a park called holiday
world in indiana
and the voyage is the second largest
wooden roller coaster in the world
and you start in one section of the park
and then you just
go out into the woods
and what's really iconic about this ride
is it has
three hills the first three hills on the
ride are all over a hundred feet so you
have these drops
one after another 100 feet or more and
so that really gives you
the air time and the voyage when it was
designed the goal
was to make an out and back roller
coaster that had more air time than any
other ride in the world that's probably
the most iconic
version of an out and back the most
nostalgic out and back that i think of
is probably the blue streak at cedar
point it's just
a classic small wooden roller coaster it
has kind of the white structure
hearkening back to the coney island
cyclone as white
[Music]
what other materials are roller coasters
made from certainly when you look at an
amusement park there are a lot of steel
roller coasters
they kind of harken back to actually
disneyland
the modern horn was actually the first
tubular steel roller coaster
and that was aero development they
worked with disney to create this ride
and from there the roller coaster just
continued to evolve
and so when cedar point built the magnum
in 1989
they broke the barrier you know of what
was really common what was knowledge
and it started a category of rides
called the hyper coaster
any roller coaster that breaks like the
200 foot mark
is considered a hyper coaster and the
magnum started the big arms race the big
coaster war that we have today and from
there
you know as our technology has improved
as different manufacturers have evolved
with new ride styles
we've gone from the hyper coaster which
was 200 feet into a new category called
the giga coaster
a giga coaster is now a ride that is in
the 300 foot range you have fury 325
or intimidator 305 kings island recently
added orion
which is also a giga coaster has that
drop that's 300 feet
so as people thirst for more and more
and something that's more and more
thrilling
the hyper coaster has become more of a
common roller coaster and then the giga
coasters i think there are only
about maybe 12 of them on the planet
right now
and then you have coasters that are even
beyond that you have these strata
coasters now
king dakot at six flags great adventure
in new jersey
is 456 feet tall and these become
highly thrilling rides that are
intimidating
to people but they're also iconic but
as you go taller and taller with a ride
you're changing that bigger potential
energy
into more kinetic energy and that that
in turn means that you have to be
concerned about the
additional speed and the duration of
some of these g-forces
not only on your body but the track as
well the impact factors
on these rides forces manufacturers to
look at more material
more steel the the foundations are
bigger and so the expense of these rides
just
exponentially increases as well
[Music]
okay what other types of roller coasters
are there when a park has a lot of hills
or terrain often as a ride designer like
we want to take advantage of that
if there's a valley that you can drive
your roller coaster into you want to do
that
and so on a wooden roller coaster you
especially
have that advantage where you can make
your path
follow this terrain we can gather
information about
the hillside trees rock formations
and the great thing about that is you
make a ride that's very efficient
because there's maybe less structure
that you have to build you don't
necessarily have to build a lift hill
super high if you can take advantage of
building some of that lift on the
hillside and then if you can drop into
that valley
you have a bigger drop and increase
speed and it can just add to the
sensation sometimes at the end of a ride
if you're up on one elevation and you
can just drop off the hill
into the valley it just adds so much
speed to the ride
typically rides as you go on they feel
like they're getting a little bit slower
and slower the hills have to get smaller
but if you have terrain you can go into
that valley toward the end of the ride
and suddenly have a 50-foot drop that
maybe you couldn't have had otherwise
and in many ways what i love about them
is they're they're kind of like
high-speed nature trails
you know you have the trees or rock
formations that you're just
whipping past you super fast it just
gives you that thrill that you're going
maybe a little bit faster than you
really
are what's the best example of a terrain
coaster the beast here at kings island
it's probably the most iconic of the
terrain roller coasters
it also is the longest wooden roller
coaster in the world
and it's been the longest wooden roller
coaster for a long time
i mean it's over 40 years old
the wild mouse it's just a classic style
ride
it can be made out of steel or they can
be made out of wood
when i think about a wild mouse the
thing that's most iconic about them is
the hairpin turn so you go up a lift
hill and then you do a lot of zigzags
but when you're doing these zigzags
they're super tight i mean they might be
like a 10 12 foot radius or even smaller
and you typically have maybe
one or two cars maximum that make up the
length of the train
so when you're making these sharp turns
that are unbanked there's a high lateral
force or a horizontal g-force that you
experience
another thing is there's not structure
underneath you so
you go out way over and it's just
straight down and you're in this tight
car and you have a feeling like is this
safe should i be doing this
and so it's those turns those tight
turns
on the wild mouse that really make it
special one of my favorite wild mice is
uh
like the villa moose at grunerland and
the reason i love that ride
is uh it's it's a very large wild mouse
and it's also
in and around all of these other rides
in the park as well
and that just adds to the thrill it
invites the guests that are walking
through the park into that ride
experience
[Music]
what's a good introductory roller
coaster mine train coasters in general
are a free-form ride
there's not a set rule that they have to
follow
but the trains they're these boxy trains
with a relatively simple chassis
or carriage or wheel system to give it
that rickety look and there's
essentially a ride that gives you that
out of control feeling
like indiana jones or something where
there are tracks all over the place
it wasn't necessarily about speed it
wasn't necessarily
about the height it was about being out
of control
and that's what mine trains were great
for is just introducing
your guests to that first roller coaster
[Music]
experience
okay what can you tell me about launched
roller coasters
you know that you're on a launch roller
coaster if you're sitting in the station
and then like five seconds later you're
going through an inversion
or or something at uh like 70 or 80
miles per hour like crazy
what we're doing on a launch roller
coaster is we're using
some external means like a linear
synchronous motor
a fancy way of saying like these
electromagnets that just in a line they
just
shoot you out super fast or a flywheel
launch
or a hydraulic launch where they're
focusing the energy of something
into a device that maybe propels you
quickly using like a cable or something
but in general you don't have to have
that lift hill in front of you you could
be flat on the ground
and just go zero to 60 like no one's
business what's a good example
the incredi coaster is an example of a
launch roller coaster
that one they wanted it to look like a
traditional roller coaster so there's
some uphill portion to the launch other
launch roller coasters there's like
thunderbird
at holiday world which is a winged
coaster in addition to being a launch
roller coaster
[Music]
okay what other elements are roller
coaster engineers playing with
aside from just the configuration of the
ride in terms of the path
the other thing that we can play with as
a ride designer is the configuration of
how guests are seated on the ride
instead of being a traditional car where
you're just sitting there are cars where
you are
standing such as green lantern there are
rides where you're
flying and you're on your belly going
through the elements
there are other roller coasters where
instead of sitting facing forward
i might have a car or two where i'm
sitting backwards
sometimes parks opt to take a ride and
run it backwards
batman the ride and many six flags parks
they've opted to run their batman rides
backwards during certain seasons
another thing that we can do with the
roller coaster is we can put you under
the track
so instead of riding in a car that's
directly above the track
now we're below the track and there were
suspended roller coasters
like the big bad wolf at busch gardens
in williamsburg
where you're on this cart below the
track and as you go around the curves
the car actually kind of swings out and
swings back
a more modern version of a ride where
you ride below the tracks
is something called an inverted roller
coaster
and the great thing about an inverted
roller coaster you have your legs
they're just dangling freely on the ride
and that just adds a completely
different sensation when you're going
through a valley
and you go down that that drop and you
hit the bottom
suddenly you know like your feet weigh
uh
you know four or five times what they're
used to and you can feel that
monster it's being built at grunerland
this year in sweden
and that's one where it's an inverted
roller coaster and they have so many
buildings
and other rides that are so close
together at this park
you're gonna feel like you're going to
hit something with your foot almost
at alton towers they had a ride called
nemesis that they built which is an
inverted roller coaster
and there are height limits at some
parks
and you can't build a rod that's very
tall so nemesis what they did
is they cleverly built these canyons or
gorges
that the ride dives into it just adds so
much to the ride experience
on a wing coaster what you do is you
have the track
in the center but you're outside of the
track so when you're riding this ride
you don't necessarily see the track in
front of you as much as
you know you see this this other land
beside you thunderbird
at holiday world is a great example of
that tron's
motorbike coaster at shanghai disneyland
is an example of something where
i'm riding this ride and it's as though
i'm on the light cycle
from tron and so the position that i'm
riding this roller coaster is completely
different
by mixing up the configuration of how
you're seating
it just adds a whole new dimension to
the ride
any other types yeah the 40 coaster
which is a
kind of abbreviation for the fourth
dimension roller coaster is just
something where they were trying to
take the standard roller coaster and add
another element to it
what they did is they took a winged
roller coaster so i'm off the side of
the track
but i'm free to spin upside down while
i'm on this ride and so you have a crazy
course
but at the same time you're spinning out
of control
around and around and when you're
spinning freely like that every ride is
different
[Music]
so what new kinds of roller coasters are
engineers envisioning
yeah i mean i think um what we're seeing
in the amusement industry is just a
blend
of technology with rides you know
certainly
i think that you can add vr or augmented
reality to rides there are some roller
coasters that have already tried the the
virtual reality
you know that's certainly a possibility
and i think that you know there's a
further
blending of just fine-tuning the
technology
how we play with the launches and the
storytelling
at hagrid's motorbike adventure you know
they added extensive theming
and there's sort of a story along with
the the roller coaster experience other
things that you
you can look for and i think that what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
take
modern technology and apply it to
something that traditionally has been
very handcrafted we're trying to take
something that is a 100 year old
technology
and make something new out of it to
reinvent it
and that's that's the goal of the whole
industry you know
this steel tubular track ride how can i
reinvent it how can i
what else can i do and i mean i could
tell you some stuff right now
but uh i'd get in trouble